bigger floods hotter fires more powerful
storms the impact of global warming is
devastating to so many people it happens
I mean it's bad enough the first time we
had insurance this time we don't but
we'll make it we always do with God's
help so disasters are also costly to
insurance companies they have responded
by raising rates at an average of more
than 12 percent compared to a year ago
2021 saw uh 20 billion dollar natural
disasters so that has had a huge impact
on insurance companies ability to pay
out claims insurance companies in the
U.S are profit driven and often lightly
regulated on a state-by-state basis
after disasters they are often quick to
raise rates even while raking in
handsome profits if you hear them tell
it you know when they're before a
legislative committee or a government
agency or in the media oh this were
broke we've we've been losing money for
10 years that is one of the biggest lies
that the insurance industry likes to
tell people they never lose money take
flood insurance as an example private
insurance companies don't provide it the
federal government does have a flood
insurance program but it isn't cheap I
don't have flood insurance
they just said six months ago we were on
a flood plain
and said you should get it well it was
quite a bit of money homeowner policies
generally cover fires but some companies
try to get around honoring claims in
full for example by treating smoke
damage as separate from fire and
severely limiting compensation for it
the minute they have to write a check to
us to pay a claim we made they're at
that money's gone for them so their
incentive is completely to hang on to
our premiums companies also simply
cancel homeowner policies and refuse to
insure people living in at-risk areas
like wildfire zones but it's going to
leave a lot of homeowners in a tough
spot down the road because they'll have
to figure out you know what to do next
where to move to they'll have to kind of
upend their lives the insurance industry
and its push for profits could drive big
changes in where people are able to live
for example here on the ocean front
which is subject to rising sea levels
and storms Global warm isn't going away
but for many people who aren't
millionaires insurance coverage may be
rapidly Getting Out Of Reach Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles